muito obrigado
como vocês viram eu uso muito os grampos
para caracterizar essa personagem que eu
faço há muitos anos a dona bilica
na verdade ela interpreta a personagem
há mais de 30 anos
[Música]
eu só aprender leão mil sou atriz e hoje
eu fiquei bastante lisonjeada com o
convite nesse ted aqui de floripa por
que me veio muito uma uma imagem
protagonismo e veio essa coisa da
máscara né
é a cada grande que eu tiro aqui pra mim
tem uma força incrível porque é uma
basca que eu tô tirando pra eu voltasse
a wanderléia eu tive que tirar essas
máscaras e criar esse e se essa fala pra
vocês não foi nada fácil pra mim eu
tenho experiência em teatro há mais de
30 anos também e agora estou com 48 anos
e eu estou no meio de uma crise é essa
essa fala me ajudou muito nessa crise é
por que carregamos tantas máscaras da
nossa vida
porque o nosso dia a dia carregado de
tantas máscaras e nós mulheres a gente
sim muito disso no nosso dia nossas
relações
até no nosso trabalho pra mim é muito
fácil eu sou atriz eu coloco a
personagem né e vou interpreto mas não
sou atriz e sua produtora eu sou
empresária eu sou tona - o dono do meu
próprio negócio e para cada papel eu
crio uma máscara tem sim a gente cria
máscaras e nas nossas relações pessoais
com nossos pais que os nossos filhos com
a mãe o marido com a esposa
a gente tem máscaras querendo ou não a
gente cria as máscaras
às vezes a gente tem que ser mais forte
às vezes a gente é mais fraca a gente
tem mais poder ter menos poder em tudo a
gente cria muitas máscaras e foi muito é
é significante é essa vinda aqui pra mim
porque em meio a uma crise dos 48 anos
eu pensei por que não eu não posso
passar por uma crise e descobri que eu
posso tirar essa máscara da crise e
viver é intensamente por que não fazer
isso por que eu tenho que fazer aquele
papel da crise da sofredora que está
passando na então
e aí eu falei pros meninos vão durar
quando me convidaram e interessantes é
protagonismo feminino
eu tiro as máscaras mas ao mesmo tempo
eu sou protagonista de mim mesmo então
fiquem nossa protagonista é a coisa que
me a nós mas almejamos na vida ser
protagonistas nesser tem o papel
principal aparecer está em evidência
está ali então quantos papéis a gente
assim
fui pra seu protagonista seu melhor
então é protagonismo feminino fiquei nos
e aí eu queria agradecer o convite e
deixar essa pergunta assim pra vocês né
de todas essas máscaras que a gente
carrega de tudo o que a gente é na vida
fazer essa pergunta é né não importa a
idade que você tem um em que momento da
vida você está
eu para criar a personagem dona bilica
me inspirei em várias pessoas da vida
real vários donativos para as pessoas
que me emprestaram as histórias delas
para eu criar essa máscara para eu ser
protagonista dona bilica e vocês qual a
história real da sua própria vida né
você é essa pergunta que eu queria
deixar você já pensou se você é
protagonista de si mesmo você é
protagonista de si mesmo você já assumiu
a sua vida às suas próprias mãos e já
decidiu qual vai ser o papel que você
vai ter
sem ficar querendo fazer um papel pra
alguém qual é a sua a sua potência qual
o seu valor
neco qual os seus o sua alegria então
com o riso com alegria que eu causei
vocês eu eu fui muito feliz e deixo aqui
meu agradecimento
e vamos ser protagonista das nossas
próprias vidas
muito obrigada